la abstención fue la gran protagonista
en mexico menos del 20 por ciento del
electorado acudió a las urnas en el
referendo revocatorio impulsado por el
gobierno de andrés manuel lópez obrador
para que la consulta fuera vinculante la
participación debía superar el 40 por
ciento en relación con la respuesta que
se le revoque el mandato en la votación
se estima en un entre un límite inferior
de 6.4 por ciento y 7.8 por ciento como
límite superior respecto de la respuesta
a la pregunta que sigue en la
presidencia de la republica de la
republica el porcentaje de votación se
encuentra entre un límite inferior de 90
punto tres por ciento y noventa y 1.9
por ciento
el mandatario que según las encuestas
hasta marzo de este año tiene una tasa
de popularidad que ronda el 60 por
ciento acogió con beneplácito las cifras
y calificó la jornada de histórica más d
15 millones de mexicanos
están
contentos
y quieren que yo continúe hasta
septiembre del
2024 sin embargo para gustavo llos
dirigentes de la oposición y de la
campaña así por méxico los resultados
son un revés para lópez obrador en 2018
el candidato am lo obtuvo más de 30
millones de votos para llegar al poder
en 2022 tras 40 meses de gobierno miles
de millones en programas clientelares y
violación sistemática de las reglas del
proceso el presidente apenas supera 16
millones para quedarse otras de las
críticas en torno al referendo fue el
gasto económico y las campañas
publicitarias los opositores aseguran
que la jornada se realizaba para medir
el índice de popularidad del presidente
y abrir la posibilidad de extender los
límites del mandato en un país donde el
jefe de estado solo puede cumplir un
único período de seis años